[Music]
what made you decide that playing a pile
of rocks was the way to go because
that's pretty much indicative of my
acting it's like a giant pile of rocks
shapeless kind of rocky tough exterior
but on the exact like the Hulk except
he's not oh [ __ ] my characters are a lot
more mature
I think Hulk is like a three-year-old
inside that [ __ ] I am hooking boy every
time I through you always come back to
me sounds like you had a pretty special
and intimate relationship with this
hammer and then losing it was almost
comparable to losing a loved one it's a
nice way of putting it what was going on
in your mind when you found out you had
Cate Blanchet there's an opportunity to
give an up-and-coming actor a shot at
just something you know creative and I
wanted to I love supporting newcomers
and I love mentoring people you want to
see something like that coming up just
got a lot of talent it's sort of
unfocused darling you have no idea
what's possible is that how it was with
Jeff Goldblum to another up-and-comer
you thought maybe you could give some
help - yeah I don't know what you think
you have to keep first piano something
you know they're all good kids these
actors we're more kind of a compliment
it is so nice of them of you to give
them a big break and that's part of my
role as a mentor / Idol / God / director
/ hero to these people is to give them
mr. pull the I'm climbing up to the top
of the mountain I'm pulling the bill by
holding onto ropes
dangling and I'm like pulling leaver
we're not behind me I'm getting the top
come up with me guys I'm not gonna leave
you behind
I'm gonna go to the top of the mountain
to the peak of success and aspirational
goals and we're at the top now giving
the apex you guys are coming with me you
stand just below the peak just down the
above my feet that is and then we're
gonna there's like wind up there I
didn't like lightning it's like a
fantasy film poster he's a fire
[Music]